hey i am Sene
and I work as an HBO
nurse at the harrier residential care center
as a HBO nurse
Are you the functional
manager of the employees in your team
and you ensure the quality
of care is guaranteed and in order
organizes your team like this
Keep discussing your work
you guard the bed occupation
the staffing
you think along about the development of healthcare policy
and much more
you are the one
that can inspire colleagues
to provide the best possible care
so you are strong in your shoes
and you HAVE 1 helicopter view
Are you accessible
but you also dare to make decisions
Are you good at giving and receiving feedback
and Would you like to develop further
apply now via Werkbijzorggroep Almere NL
and hopefully see you soon